welcome back everyone this is part two
in our series on contextual
representations we've come to the heart
of it the Transformer architecture while
we're still feeling fresh I propose that
we just dive into the core model
structure and I'm going to introduce
that by way of a simple example I've got
that at the bottom of the slide here our
sentence is The Rock Rules and I've
paired each one of those tokens with a
token representing its position in the
string
the first thing that we do in this model
is look up each one of those tokens in
its own embedding space so for word
embeddings we look those up and get
things like x47 which is a vector
corresponding to the word the and that
representation is a static word
representation that's very similar
conceptually to what we had in the
previous ERA with models like word to
VEC and glove
we do something similar for these
positional tokens here and get their
Vector representations and then to
combine them we simply add them together
Dimension wise to get the
representations that I have in green
here which you could think of as the
first contextual representations that we
have in this model
on the right here I've depicted that
calculation for the C input part of this
sequence and that's a pattern that I'm
going to continue all the way up as we
build this Transformer block just
showing the calculations for the C
Dimension because the calculations are
entirely parallel for a and for B
so to get C input we simply add together
x34 with P3 and that gives us C input
the next layer is the attention layer
this is the part of the model that gives
rise to that famous paper title
attention is all you need and the reason
the paper has the title attention is all
you need is that the author saw what was
happening in the previous ERA with
recurrent neural networks where people
had recurrent mechanisms and then they
added a bunch of attention mechanisms on
top of those recurrences to further
connect everything to everything else
and what the paper title is saying is
you can get rid of those recurrent
connections and rely entirely on
attention hence attention is all you
need that's an important historical note
because the Transformer has many other
pieces as you'll see but they were
saying in particular I believe that you
could drop the recurrent mechanisms
the attention mechanism that the
Transformer uses is essentially the same
one that I introduced in the previous
lecture coming from the pre-transformer
era it is a DOT product based approach
to attention
I've summarized that here you can see in
the numerator we have C input dot
product with a input and C input dot
product with B input let me show you
what those look like so here I've got
depicted each dot product is a DOT and
the arrows going into it correspond to
the components that feed into that
calculation so that this dot here
corresponds to a input combined with C
input and this one a input with B input
we do that same thing for the B step and
then we do the same thing for the C step
so the two dots that are depicted here
correspond to the two dot products that
are in this numerator
one new thing that they did in the
Transformer paper is normalize those dot
products by the square root of DK DK is
the dimensionality of the model it is
the dimensionality of all the
representations that we have talked
about so far that's a really important
element of the Transformer we're going
to do a lot of additive combinations in
this model and that means that
essentially every representation has to
have the same dimensionality and that is
DK there is one exception to that which
I will return to but all the states that
I depict on this slide need to have
dimensionality decay and what the
Transformer authors found is that they
got better scaling for the dot products
when they normalized by the square root
of that model dimensionality as a kind
of heuristic
so those normalized dot products give us
a new Vector Alpha with the tilde on top
we softmax normalize that and that gives
us Alpha which you could think of as
kind of attention scores
to get the actual attention
representation corresponding to this
block here we take each component of
this Vector Alpha and multiply it by
each one of the representations that
we're attending to so alpha 1 by a input
Alpha 2 by B input and then we sum those
values together to get C attention
and as a reminder we have all these
dense connections for all of these
different states I'm just showing you
the one the calculations for C attention
and that's important because all those
lines that are now on the slide are
really the only place at which we knit
together all of these columns which will
otherwise be operating independently of
each other so this really gives us all
the dense connections that we think are
so powerful for the Transformer learning
what sequences are like
now I do think that this the
representations that I have in Orange
are attention representations but
they're kind of raw materials because
they're really just recording the kind
of similarity between our Target
representation and the representations
around it to get an actual attention
representation in the Transformer what
we do is add together these contextual
representations down here with these
attention values and that gives us the
representations in yellow see a layer
and those are kind of full-fledged
attention-based representations
I've depicted the calculation over here
and that includes a nice reminder that
we actually applied Dropout to the sum
of the orange and the green Dropout is a
simple regularization technique that
will help the model to learn diverse
representations as part of its training
the next step is layer normalization and
this is simply going to help us with
scaling the values we're going to adjust
them so that we have zero mean and a
nice normal distribution falling off of
that zero mean and that's just a happy
place for machine learning models in
general
the next step is really crucially
important these are the feed forward
components in the Transformer I have
depicted them as a single representation
in blue but it's really important to see
that this is actually hiding two feed
forward layers we take c a norm and
purple here as the input and we feed
that through a dense layer with
parameters W1 and B1 and we apply a relu
activation to that
that is fed into a second dense layer
with parameters W2 and bias term B2 and
that gives us cff
and this is important because many of
the parameters for the Transformer are
actually hidden away in these feed
forward layers and in fact this is the
one place that we are where we could
depart from this dimensionality Decay
because a c a norm here has
dimensionality Decay by Design
but since we have two feed forward
layers we have the opportunity to expand
out to some larger dimensionality if we
want as long as the output of that goes
back down to DK and as we'll see for
some of these very large deployed
Transformer architectures people have
seized this opportunity to have really
wide internal layers in this feed
forward step and then of course you have
to collapse back down and that might be
giving these models a lot of their
representational power
but we collapse back down to DK for cff
here then we have another edition of CA
Norm with CAF cff to get cff layer here
in yellow and we have Dropout applied to
cff that's that regularization step and
then finally we have a layer
normalization step just as we had down
here which will help us with rescaling
the values that we've produced thus far
and therefore help the model learn more
effectively
that is the essence of the Transformer
architecture there are a few more
details to add on but I feel like this
gives you a good conceptual
understanding we began with position
sensitive versions of static word
embeddings
we had these attention layers down here
and then we have the feed forward layers
up here in between we have some
regularization and some normalization of
the values but the essence of it is
position sensitivity attention feed
forward and we are going to stack these
blocks on top of each other and that's
going to lead to lots more
representational power but all the
blocks will follow that same rhythm
since attention is so important for
these models I thought I would linger a
little bit over the attention
calculation
what I've shown you so far is the
calculation that I've given at the top
of the slide here which shows piecewise
how all of these dot products come
together and get rescaled and added in
to form C attention in this case
in the attention is all you need paper
and in a lot of the subsequent
literature that calculation is presented
in this Matrix format here
and if you're like me you might not
immediately see how these two
calculations correspond to each other
and so what I've done is just offer you
some simple code that you could get
Hands-On with to convince yourself that
those two calculations are the same and
that might help you bootstrap an
understanding of what you typically see
in the literature and then you can go
forth with that more efficient Matrix
version of the calculation secure in the
knowledge that it corresponds to the
more piecewise thing that I've been
depicting thus far
the other major piece that I have so far
not introduced is multi-headed attention
so far I have showed you effectively
single-headed attention
so let's dive into what it means to be
multi-headed I'm going to show you a
worked example with three heads the idea
is actually very simple but there are a
lot of moving pieces so let's try to do
this by way of a simple example I've got
our usual sequence at the bottom here
the Rock Rules and I've got our usual
three contextual representations given
in green
we are going to do three parallel
calculations corresponding to our three
heads here's the first head we do our
same dot products as before and it is
effectively the same calculation that
leads to them with the small twist that
we have introduced a bunch of new
parameters into the calculation those
are
wq1 for queries
wk1 for keys and wv1 for values those
are depicted in Orange in this
calculation and I put them in Orange to
try to make it easy to see that if we
simply remove all of those learn
parameters we get back to the dot
product calculation that I was showing
you before we've introduced these new
matrices to provide more
representational power inside this
attention block
and the subscripts one indicate that we
are dealing with parameters for the
first attention head
we do the same thing for our second
attention head all of those dot products
but now augmented with those new learn
parameters same thing queries keys and
values but now two for the second
attention head
and we repeat exactly the same thing for
the third attention head again with
parameters corresponding to that third
head
and then to actually get back to the
attention representations that I was
showing you before we kind of reassemble
the pieces so here is the attention
representation for a
here it is for B and here it is for C
we've pieced together from all the
things that we did down here these three
separate representations and those are
what was depicted in Orange on the
previous slides but now you can see that
implicitly that was probably a
multi-headed attention process
so now I think we can summarize maybe
the one big idea that's worth repeating
is that we typically stack Transformer
blocks on top of each other so this is
the first block I've got C input coming
in and C out here but C out could be the
basis for a second Transformer block
where those were the inputs and then of
course we could repeat that process and
that is very typical to have 12 24 maybe
even hundreds of Transformer blocks
stacked on top of each other
and the other thing that's worth
reminding yourself of is that these
representations in Orange here are
probably not single-headed attention
representations but rather the mother
multi-headed ones where we piece
together a bunch of component pieces
that themselves correspond to a lot of
learned parameters
and that is again why this attention
layer is so much a part of the
Transformer architecture in addition to
the fact that that's the one place where
all of these Columns of representations
interact with each other so that
probably further emphasizes why the
attention layer is so important and why
it's good to have lots of heads in there
offering lots of diversity for this
crucial interactional layer across the
different parts of the sequence
so that is the essence of it and I hope
that you are now in a position to better
understand the famous Transformer
diagram that appears in the attention is
all you need paper I will confess to you
that I myself on first reading did not
understand this diagram but now I feel
that I do understand it
reminder that in that paper they are
dealing mainly with sequence to sequence
problems so that they have an encoder
and a decoder and so now we can see that
on the encoder side here what they've
depicted is repeated for every step in
that encoder thing so every step in the
sequence that we're processing and once
you see that you can see okay they've
used the same I use the same colors that
they did so red for the embeddings we
have multi-headed attention
um additive and layer Norm steps then we
have the feed forward part more
normalization and kind of adding
together of different representations
that's that same Rhythm that I pointed
out before that's on the encoder side on
the decoder side things get a little
more complicated we're going to return
to some of these details but the
important thing is that now we need to
do masked attention because as we think
about decoding we need to be sure that
our attention layer doesn't look into
the future we need to mask out future
States and look only into the past when
we do those dot products so that's the
masking down here but otherwise the
decoder has the same exact structure as
the encoder they do have additional
parameters on top here corresponding to
Output probabilities if we're doing
something like machine translation or
language modeling we'll have those heads
on every single state in the decoder but
if we're doing something like
classification we might have those task
specific parameters only on one of the
output States maybe the final one
but other than that you can see the same
pieces that I've discussed before just
presented in this encoder decoder phase
so I hope that helps a little bit with
the famous diagram the final thing I
wanted to say under this heading is just
that you can get an even deeper feel for
how these models work by downloading
them and using hugging face code to kind
of inspect their structure I've done
that on this slide with Bert base and
this is really Illuminating you see a
lot of the pieces that we've already
discussed this is the Bert model
it's got an embedding layer which has
word embeddings and you can see that
there are about 30 000 items in the
embedding space each one dimensionality
768 that's DK that I emphasize so much
the positional embeddings we have 512
positional embedding so that will be our
maximum sequence length and those by
definition have to have dimensionality
768 as well
we'll return to these token type
embeddings when we talk about Bert in
particular but that's kind of like a
positional embedding
then we have layer Norman Dropout so
that's kind of regularization of these
values and then we have the layers and
what you can see on this slide is just
the first layer it's the same structure
repeated for all subsequent layers down
here we have the attention layer you see
768 all over the place because that's DK
and the model pretty much defines for us
that we need to have that same
dimensionality everywhere the one
exception is that when we get down into
the feed forward layers we go from 768
out to 3072 that's that intermediate
part but then we have to go from 3072
back to 768 for the output so that we
can stack these components on top of
each other but you can see that
opportunity there to add a lot more
parameters and therefore a lot more
representational power
and as I said this would continue for
all the layers and that's pretty much a
summary of the architecture and you can
do this for lots of different models
with hugging face you can check out GPT
and Bert and Roberta and all the other
models we talk about they'll differ
subtly in their kind of graphs but I
expect that you'll see a lot of the core
pieces repeated in various flavors as
you look at those models